whoo that was really good I'm trying to
convince my brain not to kill myself
what the is neutral Oh nobody knows
sounds like something healthy though
that they'd sell at Weight Watchers
[Music]
kind of weird that they like punish you
with food in prison that seems very
juvenile
this one's highly odorous it smells like
my dog's food smells like nope I don't
like this one
I would not survive in prison
it's alright it was like an old leathery
meat with glue I don't think this is
food there's like a lack of human
respect with this that really bothers me
yeah I'd be so furious that they're
doing is like it would make me like even
matter
[Music]
[Music]
it looks real bad or just like carrot
cake it smells like the trash that
innocent food flipy oh I like this one
the best yet but now it was afraid of
this food
I'm not following that it's very
garlicky this is your every freaking day
we were like multiple meals a day that's
kind of messed up this is definitely
punishment food this is basically the
equivalent of starving people or because
who would eat this I feel like I'm
depressed now after eating this
[Music]
I feel like I'm about to eat someone's
vomit like I feel like I'm about to go
to a bar where someone threw up on the
ground and I'm gonna scoop it into my
mouth taste is okay textures all over
the place why are there raisins in it
look I know a person are you who yeah
it's like mildly better I'm chewing a
lot but I'm not getting any flavor
because it's punishment you're not
supposed to be getting any flavors no I
take it back phases are the same as
warmth just slightly different kinds of
unappetizing I don't know what good food
tastes like anymore
[Music]